Nos dicen: "Una montaña rusa tiene
c carros, cada uno con 20 asientos,
y completa r recorridos diarios. Suponiendo que
nadie puede subirse a ella más de una vez al día,
el número máximo de personas que puede subir
a la montaña rusa en un sólo día es P. Escribe
una ecuación que relacione P, c y r". Pausa
este video y trata de resolverlo. Muy bien,
antes de mirar las variables, voy a tratar de
pensar en esto de una forma sencilla. Entonces
queremos pensar en cuál es el número máximo de
personas por día y esto será igual al número
de carros en nuestra montaña rusa, es decir, el
número de carros multiplicado por el número máximo
de personas por carro. Entonces esto sólo nos
dice la cantidad máxima de personas por recorrido,
por lo que tenemos que multiplicar el número de
recorridos por día. Entonces escribo esto en otro
color, multiplicamos por el número de recorridos
por día. Ahora, ¿qué son cada una de estas cosas?
Nos han dado cantidades o variables para cada una
de ellas, el número máximo de personas por día,
esto es lo que estamos tratando de establecer
en un lado de la ecuación, es decir,
esta variable P que está aquí. Entonces diremos
que P mayúscula es igual a, ¿cuál es el número
de carros por montaña rusa? Permíteme escribirlo
de esta manera: por montaña rusa. Luego nos dicen
que la montaña rusa tiene c carros, será esta
variable anaranjada, eso es c. Ahora, ¿cuál es
el número máximo de personas por carro? Bueno,
dicen que cada uno contiene 20 asientos, así
que multiplicaría esto por 20 para esta parte, y
luego quiero multiplicar ese número por el número
de recorridos por día para toda la montaña rusa,
entonces multiplicamos por r y hemos terminado.
Podemos reorganizar esto un poco, podemos
escribir esto como: P = 20 cr, y hemos terminado.